representative alexandria ocasio-cortez
is
fired up about president joe biden's
climate agenda
after comparing it to the green new deal
earlier in the week
she's now saying this take a look
i'm feeling extraordinarily encouraged
and i think that
the significance of president biden's
executive orders communicates
a lot one is that it really communicates
that he meant what he said on the
campaign trail that he would make
climate change a central priority of his
administration and that he considers it
not just a national security threat but
frankly you know the global matter that
it is
but it also really signifi it also
really signifies
a good faith openness and relationship
to those activist communities that you
had mentioned
and senator bernie sanders is on board
as well he thinks biden's climate
executive orders are quote
very good news katie uh
i mean i i'm wondering just from a
political standpoint
um if it isn't good news for biden to
have you know
aoc bernie on board as he begins
negotiations not only with republicans
but with centrist democrats like joe
manchin
kristin cinema isn't that a good
starting point for the incoming
president
well it it's good for him in the sense
that the far left is happy with him and
therefore they're not making a lot of
noise but when it comes to
this climate change policy which kills
american union jobs i think people like
joe manchin in west virginia
would have some questions and problems
with the climate change agenda
you know it's interesting that joe biden
ran as a moderate and now all of a
sudden aoc is praising this green new
deal plan
as something that biden supports when
joe biden continuously said on the
campaign trail he doesn't support the
green new deal although he does support
some kind of
climate change legislation or executive
orders well
now we know that his vice president
kamala harris who co-sponsored the green
new deal with aoc
is getting exactly what they want when
it comes to this overwhelming
takeover of the federal government in
terms of climate change and
going after every aspect of americans
lives because you can justify it by
saying it's environmentally friendly
all right so greg let's talk about jobs
katie was just mentioning it i was
looking at the numbers you know
bank of america's outlook 5 growth in
2021 goldman sachs says
unemployment will drop in moody's is
even saying we may have full
unemployment in this country
by 2021 with biden's
climate change and stimulus package how
do you understand this
i don't i don't buy it look
i i don't have to buy it uh america was
sold a bill of goods right i mean uh
biden was supposed to be this benign
middle of the road creature
but we knew we talked about this on the
five that
he's an empty vessel for the left that's
why they had they didn't mind him being
nominated
and why bernie was actually okay with it
um remember we were talking about the
coming civil war inside the democratic
party
it's over all right basically joe biden
is wiley
coyote after bugs bunny meets him with
the steamroller
he is flattened he's not even trying to
stand up for the average american
because he can't he doesn't have the
energy
he's feeble and he's tired he is perfect
for the the hard left to he he's not in
control of this
and everybody he doesn't even know what
these executive orders are let's be
serious
sad it's actually sad
all right so jesse uh the other big news
i mentioned this yesterday is
gm you know iconic car maker says
they're not gonna make any more
gas cars by 2035
isn't that another signal that gee i
think that
things are changing and you got to get
on the cutting edge of innovation here
and that's what biden's doing
yeah i don't believe it all those
companies say that they're just looking
for handouts from the feds
juan joe just joined the squad
i mean this guy there's no daylight
between
sleepy and aoc or i should say job
killing joe as he's known maybe that's
why
aoc likes them so much remember what you
did to amazon in new york city
cost us all those jobs well joe just
cost us about 11 000 with the keystone
aoc is like oh yeah that's the kind of
guy we're looking for
come over here and join us in the squad
while we just destroy
union jobs juan and then what was it 5
000 jobs building the border walk
by fracking bans on federal lands that's
another couple hundred thousand jobs
right there
a couple hundred thousand people lost
their shirts in that trade
against those hedge fund thieves biden
just walked away into marine one and
said see you later he doesn't care juan
he's injecting vaccines into ksm and
gitmo
while my parents can't even get stuck in
the arm i mean what is i mean
what are we doing here juan
i'm telling you it's it's a puzzle jesse
jillian i just
taken that janet yellen janet yellen was
in the white house today
meeting with president biden and their
message was
the big risk is not doing enough
uh uh the big risk is doing too little
not doing enough
and they they need to be bold on all
fronts
what did you take away from that meeting
it's the 2008
housing collapse playbook and they're
putting it into action now i wish them
the best we obviously hope it works
a quick note on aoc she's saying she's
encouraged by joe biden's
climate executive orders because he's
fulfilling campaign commitments
but keep in mind that joe biden was
completely written off by progressives
during the primaries they said he's
too old he's too white he's too uh
embedded in the establishment to make
the kind of progressive change that we
want to see in this country but
right now where we are two weeks in if
you look at the 40
executive actions he's taken
progressives are very very happy with it
that's what
greg was talking about when you see
bernie sanders and liz warren and now
aoc
lining up behind these policy proposals
if we look at his record so far
it is a fairly liberal agenda by all
accounts
our